what's up everyone Aaron Sampson here if
you guys are having a hard time finding
the Ghost Recon wildlands pvp beta we
got you covered here are three really
good rounds with impressions beta dates
and where to find it don't forget to
give us the old thumbs up and subscribe
for more wild lands coverage while
you're at it tell us in the comments
below what you think of Team Deathmatch
and what other great ideas you have for
the wild land sandbox let's get to it it
is now available through September 26
it's our so it the open war beta dates
are 9 20 1 2 9 24 day window to get in
and play it but yeah open beta so here
interested it goes until the 25th and it
started today so that Scouts started
from the woods I'm gonna guess they're
out in the woods right now I'm gonna try
and put the tower I want to try and rope
it up this guy so I was doing this in
the beta and enjoying it oh those are
your commands so I have a mine that I
can put down and if they spot me they
might go from my mind
they might rain woke me your guy just
knife to somebody which is always good
ooh there's a the way that you stick the
walls is a little bit weird what's up
guy who are you running from these re
find a Friendly Fires on don't step on
my mind okay oh that's actually is there
something that indicates for you as a
teammate is a mine nearby or are they
just kind of screwed if they just run
near it oh that's a mortar drone it's
telling me okay on the roof he's
throwing later lightning angle man bro
oh there he is bye see you later
oh okay so they see him and I've got a
I've got a
see and also dropping artillery is that
what he's doing yeah so I guess they
don't really limit okay
let's even get this guy you don't really
damn it
once you stop and take cover this is
where my team's not wait now he's like
glitchy running so the best thing that I
can do right now for my team is just
keep him marked so like Airmen derping
Tim there's gonna see him coming
Horton because I have it marked or toss
grenades at him there's that my guys
that is my guy all right are we taking
any of them down where are we at here we
go I think they're all in the woods
accessing data get my shapes okay we
have many 44 brings up a good point
though he says so begins the trend of
releasing multiplayer months later for
drag out yeah yes so there's there's
like a mental game there like our guy
went for the tower we knew that that
would pull them in to try and kill him
and we were ready for the ambush so I
like it like there's it's team
deathmatch but there are things you can
do to poke and prod at the other team
that's what I would do I think every run
is just try to like we got to find the
other side and flank you guys was like
an AR or something that's nipped here
that's pretty sneaky whoever has the
drone up right now so he's saucing
grenades he's true like he should be
through most of his grenades now there
is
how's that feel compared to the kind of
bursty fire feels like I'm worried I
won't get enough rounds on target Oh
call me me out of that cool arrows okay
it's almost one of the situations where
I feel like you want to take custody of
their bodies yeah you want to just camp
their bodies right to force the other
team to revive okay so we're back online
that's why the revives in this game
actually sort of were you don't know me
says you can enable friendly fire that's
interesting so I guess there's two
different potential game type modes so
what I was actually worried about
because you get you get rewards for on
our team splitting up you get rewards
for reviving shooting
I was worried people with kind of boost
by dropping no don't don't run ahead
down no no your team in down
where is he okay you guys got the tower
which is good I think she vive right now
because they don't home those guys that
just ran by you I think they they came
to one guy came to obviously revive his
teammate so quit complaining not take a
second you engage I think I got to be
careful cuz they're actually right next
to me that's weird because you have the
thing pub so so the mini-map would have
showed you where they were there right
there should be right in front of me
right now
no I think they booked it to the I saw I
definitely thought one come up over here
okay
so you don't I thought you had the tower
though because I you saw those other two
guys yeah but then we lost them they
went off okay don't run ahead don't run
ahead by yourself
do that do that guy yeah it's a separate
download as Kate Gore's mentioned Prince
if you're trying to play this you have
to look for Ghost Recon war or ghost
sorry goes to war beta and that's a
standalone on its own to look for that
ghost war Ghost Recon war good job
you're the only one left oh they traded
a little barrel fixie all right I'm
gonna try and get him up because then
it's a two hundred unless he revives in
which case enemies get an hour and they
revived so or no it's to be three you
got an 8 left
show me that throwing arm
okay to be to do you have a grenade left
oh no he's right there there we go hey
where's our lucky one come on you got a
guy dere right that you could
potentially go right there nation all
right I'm not gonna back to drive here
they're gonna try to get the the pinch
on here hopefully oh oh so the rounds do
have a timer singer a lot more like that
pub do you like single fire like how you
keep telling your enemies go down go
down please there's so much else I'm the
rule apps are in the YouTube chat yeah I
see this immediately just go download
the Ghost Recon war mode separately it's
not part of the base game so if you're
looking to play the open beta go
download this kind of like standalone
mode essentially and do it ID just shout
go down repeatedly as you - exactly
all players though will be handled ate
or handed a free pre VP update after
release so it looks like the PvP is
actually free no awesome assuming this
is correct why do you know what have you
recruit someone else can O'Meara pie or
clarify if I'm incorrect what it looks
like the PvP mode is free yeah I have a
GameSpot article here it says wild lands
DLC detailed free PvP mode coming after
launch and that was in March so unless
things have changed it is free okay
everyone saying PvP is free thank you
cool alright thank you
we'll go with free I like free yes free
good free makes the people happy yeah so
that's cool
glad that that is a thing for
the players that did buy Ghost Recon
wildlands and want to enjoy a PvP mode
hopefully it evolves maybe people get
lucky maybe they'll get kind of like
that pub G experience I don't know if
they're gonna make that this is the
currently the only mode that you can
play which is 44 okay yeah a lot of a
lot of comments that it is coming as a
free update cool I'm glad because
actually I think it definitely expands
out an already very expansive game and
again like there's there's no other
Ghost Recon style games like this out
right now that have PvP yeah hello and
nonnamous hacker how are you and Kyle
wait Nick says can I please have your
job although I will say but thanks for
tuning in and helping me keep my job I
guess I mean also if you want to become
a youtuber sky's the limit
Jimmy I would just say wait because we
were joining a match and it took us a
few minutes just to finally get there so
just be patient don't keep backing out
of matchmaking I would say leave it
there just give it a second it will get
there I think the more and more people
are slowly downloading the beta so
you'll have more and more people to to
get matched with but for now just try to
be patient
wow I'm enduring Tain's oh no super
aggressive right flank and yeah let's
see how this goes see what happens when
you just run for it I think it'll work
especially if like people are trying to
like growing up and stuff like that
he's also must be a classic and run more
than me because like a Scouter I'm on
the other class that you kind of had a
run juice right now what's that Victor
land how are you doing so they're
drowning that means they're around here
somewhere yes frosty saying in beta you
have access to six out of the 12 classes
in eight out of the 12 maps
that's good knowledge to do start his
trainee
yeah all right recruit right you said
yes what's up Nicholas at card Dennis
your record eNOS the good chance that
they are all currently right next to me
where are they
I'm getting those away the lumber boat
we have that building okay they're in
buggy for five I think I see yeah it's
in there and that bills in there
yeah he's definitely in there oh well
pincer maneuver oh man err Manning
derping tonie's flying on the screen
here a little bit it is beta I hope he's
not cheating no I don't think no come
here and there's two of them in there
derping Tangier ohms knife um do you
interpret didn't do it dude dirty you
got him right yeah you got Wow he
glitching I have no idea he looks like
he's kind of warping around that could
just be lag I'm gonna go with lag or
because it's a beta or he found some
sweet like Bert said something I don't
know is eet bagging though is he tea
bagging okay well we took a lot of you
down there that worked out well connect
climb and just gotta camps and bodies
other bodies yeah
how many do we take down in here three
because boy I would just say keep trying
to do what you're doing
take it as a hobby person for most
[ __ ]
you tuber and just try to keep kind of
making the content that you like making
the content that's Betty's up here so
yeah I mean passions what's going to
take your audience with you yeah John
Martinez is not enjoying watching our
gameplay you don't have to be here but
you don't want to watch it nice that's
good teamwork there suppress them get
eyes on you your guy flying some boom
easy-peasy